pick up where you stopped by
culture basically you
code she was going down the drain
because nobody is supporting it anymore
and during the break we discussed a bit
more explicit you said it's especially
dire in the Netherlands worse in Germany
high culture is more supported by the
government and thus there there's
something called building spiritomb in
my question to you and maybe also Philip
can answer this is why don't we have a
thing like buildings Bluebird to minna
Netherlands and in many other places
countries in the Netherlands in the
Europe and do we need do we need us do
we need buildings burger too yeah well
if you're if you're asking me hello
wrong wrong answer I'm sorry let me
start that rubber game no points um they
actually trap doors and our chairs they
say anything really wrong we're gone um
well I hesitate to bore you with
historical platitudes but it was the way
of course it was a way of German
nationalism originally there was no
political union fully union was only in
the language and the culture and culture
has stayed I think half of all opera
houses in the world are in Germany that
is you know that is a pretty
extraordinary exception it has created a
strong sense of identity I think but it
is also and days again an elite problem
here because there are many people who
don't participate in that and until the
Second World War that was seen as
unproblematic I think today it's quite
problematic I also think the fact that
the state runs many cultural
institutions isn't only good because it
tends to sort of drift towards a
professionalized kind of taste a taste
of curators and directors who make
decisions for other curators and
directors so you know it's the opposite
of the American model where you have
hugely rich donors not only giving money
for production but also the taste so you
know they're two extremes and perhaps
neither of them is ideal but do we need
this you ask well of course that's the
greatest utopia decent education for
everyone
that would perhaps be something to build
up something like a European institution
like a European identity as well but
just to come back to that because I find
it really important how much I feel
Europe has failed to try even to build
it up in very simple things that let's
say we have in many countries military
service or civil service now first of
all it's patently absurd that only young
men do that not young women as well and
you could say okay as a trader for your
free education you do your year social
services somewhere not in your own
country in a different European country
go somewhere else for a year that is
something small and something practical
but it's not just Erasmus for again the
kids of the elite but that would be
something for everyone to see Europe is
a reality everywhere people are
remarkably like my family they have the
same problems the same fuck-ups and
actually some of them are really nice
you know that would be a way of building
your but that sort of thing is never yet
happened and I think that's where we
fail terribly to build that up the
Germans in the French have done this for
a long time they're still doing it and
now in your answer don't you know in a
large program that that really grips
everyone but if we want to teach to make
people feel that there actually is
something like it belonging together in
this Europe we need to think harder and
we need to think harder about something
that is part of ordinary people's lives
not just something for the elite which
is European anyway and has always been
European and another thing when you
earlier said people now no longer fight
with weapons but with words well we are
rich we don't need to fight with weapons
we all have enough wait until still real
poverty returns to Europe and see
whether people will only fight with me
with you so angry
you know and that of course is also why
this is not just a nice sort of ornament
the cherry on the cake of European
culture to have you know to to create
this European identity but by why it's
necessary because we've all grown up and
lived most of us in a time of wealth and
security in Europe indeed an
unprecedented one now whether that is
only due to the European Union or not i
think is a very debatable point but it
is not necessarily what the future will
look like we will all be poorer in the
future we will all face more challenges
and we need to create something that can
be sure we will all be poor this is
something it is like a law is this swype
I feel way to convey I think it's I
think it's slightly it's something like
an offer for instance because of climate
change because work process will be
increasingly automated most people more
than half of their people with the
people will lose their jobs in the next
30 years but then we always know we all
know from history that all these
innovations also create new jobs well
that's not all of them and as you can
see I think that's a little a mystic
vision but you know we are facing up to
huge challenges and changes in the next
generation and we'd better have
something to counter them with we'd
better think into the future and I think
at the moment we're sort of
administrating our wealth and that's
great but it won't be enough yeah could
I just make an economic point here I
don't I do agree that we will probably
be poorer over time if we continue to
measure wealth just through GDP yes
they're very important that's a very
important I mean you know there are I
mean if we if we start using welfare
measures rather than GDP measures as
actual GDP the kind of gdp represented
by commercial transactions between
people declines as a share other forms
of activity will rise and so I mean we
need to re-examine our concepts of
wealth welfare sufficiency all these
things that are barely
on the horizon yet of political
discussion
you